io sono nata e cresciuta a roma ha
vissuto fino all'adolescenza nella città
militare della cecchignola avendo un
papà ufficiale dell'esercito
il nostro parco giochi da bambini era il
poligono di addestramento dei militari e
diciamolo pure ero un maschiaccio
essendo l'unica femminuccia tra gli
amici della stessa fascia di età per cui
occhiate gravi e dimostrare che potevi
fare le stesse cose che facevano i
maschietti orari esclusa evidentemente
la battaglia del gender and quality l'ho
iniziata molto presto
ho iniziato a nuotare quasi prima di
camminare il mare ha sempre presentato
per me un fascino magnetico e una
passione smisurata
forse all'epoca ancora non avevo capito
quello che volevo diventare da grande
ricordo bene che volevo fare
l'astronauta ma richiamo del mare è
stato più forte di tutto
a 16 anni ho iniziato a praticare
subacquea 21 ero diventata distruttore
nel frattempo ci siamo anche studi
universitari alla facoltà di ingegneria
aeronautica per poi passare da loro
spaziale perché vi ho detto il mio sogno
era quello dello spazio mentre
conciliamo il mio tempo tra insegnamento
privato di pianoforte visto che avevo
anche un diploma al conservatorio e la
scuola subacquea in pratica mi allenavo
job da giovane al multitasking cosa che
mi è tornata molto utile nel mio lavoro
attuale sono sempre stata una persona
guidata dal proprio cuore dalle proprie
sensazioni e una che deve sempre dare il
massimo in quello che fa e ho cominciato
in quegli anni a maturare un
insofferenza per la vita cosiddetta
normale la vita da ufficio 85 le ore di
traffico da e per l'ufficio
non che abbia mai fatto quella vita ma
mi bastava osservarlo agli altri per
capire di volere qualcosa di diverso per
me e quindi la decisione di esplorare mi
opzione il desiderio di lavorare sul
mare mi ha portato ad andare in
australia quasi 25 anni fa pensando di
continuare la mia carriera nella
subacquea in realtà in modo del tutto
accidentale dopo solo per quattro giorni
dal mio arrivo a cans nello stato il
quiz lando vera ondata mi sono ritrovato
a lavorare temporaneamente per un paio
di settimane su una piccola esclusiva
nave da crociera la nave con base a
cairns esplorava la parte nord della
grande barriera corallina e io ricoprivo
luoghi dal master and back end
praticamente istruttori sub marinaio
le due settimane sono diventati tre anni
fantastici
anni di avventure su quella nave che si
chiamava riferita dove ho sviluppato la
mia esperienza ho creato coltivato
amicizia per la vita lavorare su una
nave a tempo pieno mi ha fatto
improvvisamente scoprire un nuovo mondo
che mi ha fatto realizzare che esisteva
una nuova opportunità per me a parte la
subacquea
ho iniziato quindi a studiare a
conseguire patenti nautiche nostrani
affinché grazie ad un'amica ottenuto il
mio primo colloquio per uno yacht mentre
ancora vivevo a casa
lo yacht era da esplorazione si trovava
in australia per manutenzione qualche
mese dopo quel colloquio il comandante
mi chiamò e mi offrì il lavoro di tarso
ufficiale dal master e da lì ho scoperto
il mondo dei super yacht cioè dei grandi
yacht con equipaggio fisso professionale
e sono entrato a farne parte
su quello che 8 e le cose non andarono
come avevo desiderato certamente per
colpe non mie ma come tutti gli episodi
negativi sia della mia vita privata che
di quella professionale mi ha insegnato
molto su me stessa e sulla mia
resilienza termine molto di moda al
momento
d'altronde la vita delle persone di
successo ci insegna che solo chi alza
chi si alza quella volta in più o meglio
tutte le volte necessarie dopo una
caduta
arriva a raggiungere quello che si è
prefissato e che ha sognato
non arrendersi mai e trasformare tutte
le esperienze negative elezioni di
apprendere per migliorarsi sempre
apple già e isolina è come si direbbe in
inglese da quella prima esperienza si
sono susseguiti anni di studio lavoro ho
avuto il privilegio di lavorare su
alcuni degli yacht più prestigiosi e per
armatori di alto profilo internazionale
quando parliamo del mondo dei super
yacht molto spesso ignoriamo quello che
gli occhi non vedono per me erano quelle
navi incredibili che vedevo da bambino a
porto cervo quando andava in sardegna in
vacanza ma il muto che si celava al suo
interno era un mistero che non avrei
neanche saputo come svelare dopo i primi
lavori nello iotti che studi malata in
collegi primo se in inghilterra 20 anni
fa ho conseguito la patente da
comandante e ottenuto il primo comando
dino liotta bella di circa 40 metri
l'anno successivo è stato quello che ha
segnato una svolta molto importante ho
scelto di fare un passo indietro tornare
ad essere un ufficiale per prendere
parte al progetto di costruzione di
quello che all'epoca era lo yacht più
grande mai costruito al mondo quello gli
otto si chiamava 8 per cento 26.2 metri
di lunghezza ed è a tutt'oggi forse il
più iconico degli explorer di oggi
se dovessi descrivere il tempo che ho
trascorso suo autobus quello che mi
viene in mente sono le parole delle
canzoni degli eurythmics sui grisa mail
o this world sensi ho letteralmente
viaggiato il mondo e i sette mari q7
oceanico quello yacht se dovessi
cominciare a spiegare cosa hanno
significato quegli anni su 8 bus per la
mia vita
personale e professionale
avremmo decisamente bisogno di più tempo
prima di tutto vorrei dirvi che
incredibile privilegio si è stato
lavorare e condividere esperienze
memorabili con paul allen paul alle per
quelli che non lo sapessero è stato il
co fondatore della microsoft
che ha lasciato attivamente dopo essere
sopravvissuto all'informa di oggi
all'età di 30 anni e che ha creato
successivamente la sua società vulcan
perseguire tutte le sue vocazioni i suoi
sogni avendo capito dopo quella
esperienza che la vita era un attimo che
andava vissuto intensamente
la sua vita è terminata in effetti
troppo presto circa quattro anni fa paul
era un visionario di heidi e man come il
titolo del suo libro aveva un'anima
bella e generosa
il mondo è decisamente un posto più
povero senza di lui
con lui esplorato relitti sommersi mai
visti prima mi sono immersa con un
sottomarino a 350 metri sotto la
superficie dell'oceano
ho navigato in antartica è volato in
elicottero sulla cima dei suoi ghiacciai
mi sono immersa con centinaia di squali
martello e squali balena posti sito alla
produzione nello studio di registrazione
a bordo della che era bordo dello yacht
dell'album supera capi un progetto one
off del supergruppo che era composto da
jagger johnston the cure eurythmics e
ritornano in campo e romana interni e
molle o pianificato grandi eventi a
bordo in occasione della biennale d'arte
e della mostra del cinema di venezia che
ho preso parte alle visioni delle
olimpiadi di atene e torino
ho conosciuto miliardario oleg stage
rock stars con lavorato durissimo
mi sono divertito al mondo e ho imparato
tantissimo ho semplicemente
un'esperienza memorabile che vale una
vita intera
vivere navigare gli oceani del mondo che
arricchisce la vita
avere la possibilità di scoprire
innumerevoli posti culture diverse ti
apre la mente
creare momenti unici e irripetibili per
gli ospiti a bordo mi dà molta
soddisfazione
sapendo che hai contribuito a creare
memorie indimenticabili per loro e tra
albe e tramonti con colori mozzafiato
giorni pieni di sfide professionali
notti insonni una vita personale piena
di sacrifici
ti guardi intorno e ancora di certe
stessa che è un lavoro fantastico
dopo i sei anni e mezzo trascorsi su 8
nel 2009 ho deciso che era arrivato il
momento di tornare a cercare di nuovo
una posizione da comandante ed è qui che
le cose si sono fatte più difficili ho
dovuto attendere fino al 2014 e cinque
anni dopo dopo un paio di lavori da
ufficiali su grandi yacht è un ritorno
alle origini sono nave da crociera dove
ci sono decisamente più possibilità di
affermarsi per una donna
sono stato approcciato dal management di
uno yacht chiamato mariù dagli otto
costruito interamente disegnato da
giorgio armani
il core motore va specificamente
richiesto una donna per il comando bingo
con poca competizione è stato facile
assicurarmi il lavoro e da quel momento
ho continuato la mia carriera al comando
nello yachting al momento solo il 2 per
cento delle donne sono una posizione di
comando è un'industria privata e
certamente per gli o superiore 50 metri
spesso la nazionalità degli armatori
gioca un ruolo importante
spesso sono nazionalità che non
metterebbero
normalmente donne in posizioni io che
per ragioni culturali non desiderano
alla donna comandante detto ciò ho
lavorato per armando russi per esempio
che in passato tradizionalmente erano
restii a donne in carica che invece non
hanno avuto questo tipo di problemi con
me
il numero di donne che lavora in coperta
o sul ponte di comando in sala macchine
rispetto al passato e di molto cresciuto
industria dello gli occhi sta certamente
prestando maggiore attenzione alle donne
e spero che noi della vecchia
generazione
stiamo creando un esempio da seguire per
le nuove generazioni
certamente un altro aspetto importante
da tenere in considerazione per una
donna che vuole intraprendere questo
tipo di carriera e bilanciare la propria
vita personale e quella professionale
che a volte un freno importante avere
figli quando fai questo lavoro a tempo
pieno è molto difficile diventa quasi
impossibile se non si possiede un
supporto familiare adeguato serve una
tribù perché share i figli è
praticamente vorrei che chiarire che le
donne non hanno bisogno di alcun
privilegio non sono qui a parlarvi di
questo devono guadagnarsi le promozioni
come chiunque altro ma questo non vuol
dire che debbano sempre per forza essere
meglio di nuovo per ottenere un
opportunità ho avuto certamente i
momenti nella mia carriera dove essere
donna e stato uno svantaggio
la verità è che per essere considerata è
riscattata deve essere migliore di un
uomo e per raggiungere certe posizioni
ci potrebbe volere di più che per un
uomo per una donna e una posizione
senior di comando essere quindi mediocre
non è tollerato e dire giustamente
ma allora è nessuno si senta offeso per
un uomo ma detto ciò non avere mai come
scusa la destinazione di genere che non
avere successo
sono sempre stata convinta che
attraverso il duro lavoro impegno e
entusiasmo
preparazione studio continua
investimenti se stessi e amore che il
proprio lavoro prima o poi si
raggiungono gli obiettivi che ci si è
prefissati
vero che può essere lunga e tortuosa la
via del successo pronta mai negli occhi
come come anche per un uomo in posizioni
tradizionalmente femminili per esempio
le persone che lavorano negli interni ma
se vuoi fare di questo lavoro la
carriera della vita allora deve
accettare la sfida e rialzarti sempre
dopo ogni fallimento non importa quante
volte tu lo debba fare
suggerisco di usare tutto il tempo extra
per arrivare a proprio vantaggio per
essere meglio preparati quando
l'occasione finalmente si presenta
credere se stessi credere di poterlo
fare è non lasciarsi condizionare in
alcun modo da chi dice il contrario
il tema di questa serata il fattore
umano negli stati uniti il termine human
factor viene utilizzato per individuare
la disciplina che nel resto del mondo e
non fa come ergonomics ergonomia che per
definizione la disciplina scientifica
che studia interazioni tra essere umano
e gli altri elementi di un sistema
applicando teorie principi dati e metodi
per progettare allo scopo di migliorare
il benessere umano le prestazioni del
sistema il fattore umano si riferisce a
quegli elementi per quelli del lavoro
organizzazione e individuo che hanno
influenza sul comportamento e dunque
anche conseguenze sugli obiettivi di
salute e sicurezza le organizzazioni
svolgono le proprie attività attraverso
olimpico di due componenti fondamentali
le risorse materiali e quelle umane è
ormai diffuso l'uso del termine
fatto romano per indicare l'insieme
delle risorse umane
delle attività da queste svolte per
conseguire i fini organizzativi
questa definizione chiude tre aspetti
strettamente intercorrerà ti tra loro
l'individuo ovvero l'insieme delle
competenze ed abilità il vissuto
personale le motivazioni il lavoro
occorre considerare aspetti quali la
natura del compito il carico di lavoro
le procedure strumenti e metodi di
verifica e controllo ambientale e
l'organizzazione e dunque leadership
struttura organizzativa modalità
comunicative fini primari e secondari e
valori condivisi
sebbene sia essenziale concentrare
l'attenzione sull'individuo sulla sua
responsabilizzazione sulle sue
competenze al fine di verificare che i
suoi comportamenti siano congruenti con
i fini di valori organizzativi
occorre prima di tutto
intervenire a monte ovvero
sull'organizzazione medesima e sulle
modalità con le quali è gestito il
lavoro dal momento che i comportamenti
delle figure appartenenti a livelli
operativi sono evocati da stimoli
antecedenti modificati da conseguenze
che fanno capo alle scelte o alla loro
assenza e carenza del partito vertice
strategico
l'industria marittima dove io lavoro è
governata a livello internazionale dal
aimo international a marshall
organization ed una delle più importanti
convenzioni assistita due standard cioè
nei ser.t fiction and watchkeeping
determina le qualifiche minime standard
per comandanti ufficiali e personali di
guardia su navi mercantili grandi yacht
nel 2010 l'emendamento manuela ha
introdotto per la prima volta un
requisito di training il management e
leadership per tutti gli ufficiali co
parte di macchina il corso che si ama è
un human element leadership e management
è una delle più significative
innovazioni
che ci sono state nell'industria parenti
ma soprattutto considerando le esigenze
della consapevolezza di comandanti
ufficiali non ricevevano alcun treni
formale nel compito di gestire le
persone che sono la maggiore causa di
incidenti nell'industria marittima e la
versione tale tipologia di treni che è
stata utilizzata per anni l'industria
dell'aviazione in realtà è molto
proattiva quella marittima e reattiva
nessuno aveva pensato infatti di
utilizzarla anche a livello marittimo
fino al 2010 la realtà dei fatti è che
la maggior parte degli incidenti sono
causati da qualcuno che commette un
errore e bisogna imparare come
minimizzarli e questo credo valga per
qualsiasi ambiente lavorativo
vorrei condividere alcune statistiche
con voi per illustrare meglio il
problema le normano e responsabile del
58 per cento degli incidenti in mare
anche se la percentuale di fatto sale
quando consideriamo che anche per
esempio la carenza e la cattiva
manutenzione sono un fattore non solo
economico ma umano
le romane causa ogni singolo giorno di
collisioni incagliamenti affondamenti
incendi o esplosioni per 18 navi questo
tutti i giorni in media affondano due
navi ogni giorno la solitudine può
causare incidenti in mare la cattiva
comunicazione può causare incidenti in
mare una cattiva consapevolezza della
situazione con casa il mare e tutti
guardano al comandante nelle situazioni
sopra descritte
non si lascia leader si viene creati
come qualsiasi altra cosa attraverso il
duro lavoro e questo è il prezzo da
pagare per conseguire i propri traguardi
il mio equipaggio è formato da più di
una decina di nazionalità proveniamo da
culture in alcuni casi profondamente
diverse religioni diverse tradizioni
diverse e le nostre lingue madri sono
diverse utilizziamo l'inglese come
lingua comune viviamo in un elemento
come il male che sa essere meraviglioso
ma anche molto stile non abbiamo i
pompieri o il personale sanitario o le
forze dell'ordine ad intervenire il
nostro aiuto nel momento del bisogno a
meno che non siamo in porto per cui
dobbiamo essere noi pompieri il medico e
la sicurezza di noi stessi e dovere di
ognuno di noi di prepararsi
adeguatamente
e dovere dei leader di assicurarsi che
la conoscenza venga diffusa e promossa a
tutti i livelli mi sento di avere ruoli
diversi a seconda delle situazioni un po
comandante un po mentore un po
consigliere un po zia sorella mamma
psicologa a porta anche maestra d'asilo
eccoli più impertinenti
per concludere per concludere dice anche
la dott.sa il fattore male più grande e
mal di testa di un comandante